[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Please be sited.
Graduates, honored guests, faculty
staff, families and friends,
welcome to the graduation ceremony
for the Stanford Graduate School
of Business
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I'd first like to recognize some
of the people who are here today.
The GSB faculty and
staff have played a pivotal role in
the experience of our students.
Could I ask our faculty and
staff to stand for
a moment of thanks.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> We also are joined by
families and
friends who have provided support,
advice, and most importantly love.
Let's take a moment to recognize
our families and friends.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Finally, we have more than 500
students from the MBA, MSc, and
PhD programs.
So, let's hear it for
our graduating students.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> My opening remarks today
are about what it means to live
a good life, I'll be brief.
>> [LAUGH] >> I want to start
however with your experience
at the GSB.
When you arrived we told you that
Stanford would widen your aperture.
You would meet new people,
you would encounter new ideas,
you would have new experiences,
you've made that happen.
You tackled finance and
accounting some of-
>> [LAUGH] >> You were asked
to think hard about leadership and
about shareholder capitalism.
Some of you did original research.
>> [LAUGH] >> Some
of you were ridiculous costumes and
flew to Las Vegas for 24 hours.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> All of us
had a new experience this winter,
when we stopped using electronic
devices during class.
>> [LAUGH] >> Let me amend that,
when we tried to stop using
electronic devices during class.
[APPLAUSE] >> This spring, some of
you took what you learned and
started new companies.
Some of you danced in front of a
a thousand people in the GSB show.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Apparently,
some very funny things happened
this year at the school, but
I couldn't follow any
of the jokes in this year's show.
>> [LAUGH] >> A few weeks ago,
many of us gathered in
Bing Concert Hall for something I'd
never seen at Stanford,
the performance of classical music
and dance that showcased
extraordinary student talents.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Most importantly,
every day,
you came together with your
classmates from around the world.
You push yourselves to expand your
thinking and try new things.
And one of my great wishes for
you is to keep doing just that.
At a faculty meeting earlier this
year, my colleague Brian Lowry
handed me a paper by a psychology
professor at the University of
Chicago, named Shigehiro Oishi.
Oishi's studies what it means to
live a good life.
He is not the first, Socrates and
Aristotle got there long ago, but
Oishi has a substantively new idea.
They're two conceptions of the good
life that have been much debated in
philosophy and psychology.
The first is happiness,
the idea that we are fulfilled
through friendships and experiences
that bring joy and pleasure.
The second is meaning, namely, that
we should seek to have a purpose
and commit ourselves to it.
Aristotle called this the life of
virtue.
Oishi observes that when people
reflect back on their lives,
what they regret is generally not
things they've done or failed at,
but things they haven't done.
He argues that this tells us
something about a good life.
Living a good life means, that we
keep seeking new experiences,
keep finding new perspectives,
keep discovering new ways,
to think about the world.
These experiences needn't bring
happiness, or even purpose.
It's a third, and distinct concept.
Oishi calls this a psychologically
rich life.
This is the life you've lived at
Stanford.
But in fact, I would argue that
the GSB has prepared you for all
three dimensions of a good life.
You've made friendships that will
last decades and be a source of
great happiness and fulfillment.
You've gained the skills and
aspirations to pursue a life of
purpose and meaning.
And you've set a foundation to
continue to broaden your
perspective, to take risks, to live
a psychologically rich life.
I'm excited to watch your lives
unfold in each of these ways.
Now, I want to close with a quote
from the GSB campus.
If you walk across
the Knight Management Center,
you come upon a set of footprints,
in the pavement of Town Square.
They're the footprints of
Phil Knight,
who sat in one of these seats at
a GSB graduation some 60 years ago.
Next to the footprints is a quote
from Phil.
And it says, there comes a time in
every life when the past recedes
and the future opens.
It's a moment when you turn to face
the unknown.
Some will turn back to what they
already know, some will walk
straight ahead into uncertainty.
I can't tell you which one is
right, but I can tell you which one
is more fun.
Stanford GSB Class of 2023,
I wish you happiness, meaning, and
continued adventure, a good life,
congratulations.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Today's graduation speaker,
Henry Fernandez, has been walking
into uncertainty for decades,
with purpose and success.
Henry grew up in Nicaragua.
After coming to the United States
and considering a PhD in economics,
he came to the GSB and
completed his MBA.
Today, Henry is the Chairman and
CEO at MSCI,
the global finance firm.
He's been recognized multiple times
is one of the world's best CEOs.
In recent years, he's put MSCI at
the forefront of climate finance.
I especially admire Henry for his
passionate support of GSB students
and faculty over many years, for
his original ideas, for
his infectious energy, and for
his big heart.
Please join me in welcoming
Henry Fernandez.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Well, good afternoon, everyone.
I want to thank Dean Levin for
his warm introduction.
I would also like to welcome my
fellow trustees of the Board of
Stanford, faculty and staff,
parents, relatives and
distinguished guests.
And last, but certainly not least,
all graduating students,
it is a tremendous honor and
privilege for me to join you today.
As you may have heard or read,
I'm a proud member of the GSB class
of 83.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> And
just to confirm, even though I'm
not a young man anymore,
that was 1983, not 1883.
>> [LAUGH] >> 40 years ago,
this very month, I was sitting
exactly where you are today.
I was pleased with my graduation,
Excited, but
anxious about my next chapter, and
wondering what life would look like
in the decades to come.
I certainly have gained significant
knowledge and
experience at the GSB.
But I surely wish I had learned
much more of what I will share with
you today.
In my remarks,
I would like to impart my lifelong
learnings in several areas,
namely, the miracle of optimism,
confidence, and resilience.
The surprising benefits of failure,
the unexpected virtues of grunt
work, >> [LAUGH] >> And
the magic of aligning skills with
purpose and vision.
But before I go through them,
Just a quick and
important word about long term
perspective in life.
Perspective is the perfect remedy
for both irrational exuberance and
on do despair.
It is also essential to developing
a vision of the future.
We need long term perspective now
more than ever.
Watching the news on a year like
this can make anyone
feel pessimistic about the future.
Take it from me,
every GSB class thinks they
are graduating at a uniquely
difficult moment in history.
>> [LAUGH] >> In a way,
they're all correct.
As you go out into the world,
you will face many challenges that
did not exist in 1983, but at
the same time, you will enjoy many,
many opportunities.
Geopolitically, 1983 represented
a high point of Cold War tensions
with the Soviet Union.
Domestically, America's violent
crime rate was 35% higher in 1983
than in 2020.
Economically, the month I
graduated from the GSB, America's
unemployment rate was over 10%.
We were also emerging from
the worst inflation from
World War II.
That same month,
the Dow Jones Industrial Average
never got above 1,250 which
is as you know,
less than 4% of its level today.
My point here is not to diminish
our current problems but
rather to put them in a longer term
perspective.
It's snapshots in time,
when not taken in context can
be misleading and demoralizing, and
they can perpetuate short termism.
Thinking a longer view allows us
to observe a wider arc of human
progress and
the tremendous opportunities that
that progress brings.
My own personal perspective was
heavily shaped by the obstacles and
struggles I endure in my late teens
and my twenties.
As you can tell from my accent,
I grew up in the deep south.
>> [LAUGH] >> The very,
very deep south of Central America.
When I first came to America from
Nicaragua at age 16,
I did not speak English.
Even as I learned,
the language, many of my professors
at Georgetown,
could not understand me.
At age 21, my home country
was shaken by a very violent
communist revolution.
Suddenly, I found myself as
a political refugee in America.
Every six months, as the US
government reviewed my case, I
received a new deportation letter.
When the second letter arrived, I
told my lawyer, look, this is a big
country let them come and find me.
>> [LAUGH] >> [LAUGH] After
a while, when it became clear I
could no longer return to my native
Nicaragua, I felt totally lost.
I had no answers to the most basic
questions of life.
Where would I live?
What would I do?
When I ever feel a true sense of
identity I'm belonging anywhere.
I was not able to conquer those
demons until I got to Stanford.
In that way, the GSB was a godsend,
and helped me regain perspective
and re-imagine my future.
During my time here,
I discover my first learning.
The miracle of confidence,
optimism, and resilience.
I realize that the most successful
people in life all have
an unshakable belief in the future.
And an unwavering confidence
that they will find a path forward
through that future.
I never forgot during my first days
on campus, watching a view from
the top lecture by Nolan Bushnell.
Bushnell has created more than 20
companies including the video game,
Atari and the entertainment and
dining company Chuck E Cheese.
>> [LAUGH] >> When he came to
Stanford 1981, he focus his speech
on all his fail ventures.
This seems strange to me.
Even stranger was the fact that
everyone applauded him.
I asked myself,
what was that all about?
It took me a while to grasp that
the students were not applauding
failure, they were applauding
risk-taking.
Bushnell's point was the genuine
innovation requires us to take
risks and chances, and that failure
can have surprising benefits.
And believe me I have the scars to
prove that since I embraced that
throughout my life.
Before MSCI,
I failed in business not once,
not twice, but three times.
First, I tried to take over a
savings bank in Buffalo, New York,
very balmy weather like California.
>> [LAUGH] >> That failed.
Then I established a private equity
firm in Mexico, That failed.
>> [LAUGH] >> Then a GSB friend and
I set up a media focused private
equity firm in the US,
that failed too.
When I finally rejoined
Morgan Stanley, where my career had
started, I was almost broke.
But still, I decided to take
another big chance.
At that time,
MSCI was a failing joint venture
between Morgan Stanley and
the Capital Group,
a large investment firm.
Most people would not have consider
this joint venture a good place to
relaunch their career.
And yet,
over the past three decades we have
succeeded beyond my wildest dreams.
And we still believe that the best
is yet to come.
When you describe it that way,
MSCI seems like a Hollywood movie.
But I can assure you that it was
filled with countless obstacles,
uncertainties and setbacks.
We only achieve success because
of our willingness to risk failure.
We only achieve success because of
our willingness risk failure.
I have learned far,
far more from my failures that I
haven't learned from my successes.
I have discovered the surprising
benefits of failure,
my second learning today.
You would not be here today unless
you had a strong internal drive to
succeed.
As you continue on your path,
you should expect to do plenty of
grunt work, no matter where your
job is or what your title says.
Indeed, grunt work is
the foundation of all successful
businesses.
It is what teaches us
the discipline of execution.
Without it,
even the most brilliant strategy is
nothing more than words on a page.
It can be hard for
many smart ambitious people like
you to accept the unexpected
virtues of grunt [LAUGH] work.
My third learning in life.
To paraphrase the great American
humorist P.J. O'Rourke,
everybody wants to save the world,
nobody wants to do the dishes.
>> [LAUGH] >> If you want to change
lives, change organizations,
and change the world, you need to
do the dishes every day.
To accomplish really big things,
you first have to accomplish a lot
of really small things.
Most of those small things may be
tedious or thankless.
Even supposedly glamorous jobs
are usually not that glamorous.
Your role will be filled with grunt
work and execution.
This applies to Silicon Valley,
Wall Street and
every place in between.
Let me now return to where your GSB
experience first began.
The admissions application essay.
I hope this does not evoke bad
memories.
>> [LAUGH] >> At the time,
you had to explain what matters
most to you and why.
The point of the exercise was
to bring out the authentic self
in you.
Stanford was not looking for
a grandiose statement about
the destiny of humankind, or
radical solutions to climate change
and sustainable growth, or
the next technological revolution.
Instead, they wanted to know what
gives your life meaning.
Not somebody else's life,
your life.
The GSB wanted you to focus on what
really matters to you.
They wanted to know what the
purpose and vision of your life is.
Whatever path you choose,
do not let ambition stand in
the way of your purpose.
Each of you has a different set
of priorities,
a different set of skills, and
a different sense of purpose.
Your ultimate goal should be to
bring all of it
into proper alignment.
To achieve great feats in life,
it is not enough to develop
separate skills,
you also have to discover the magic
of aligning those skills and
connecting them with your purpose,
your vision of the future.
That alignment of skills and
that connection to purpose
represents my biggest and
most important lesson in life.
I have tried to apply all these
learnings throughout my life.
This has meant maintaining optimism
about the future and
gaining confidence that I
will always find a path forward.
I will always figure out the way
using the lessons of my failures as
building blocks for success,
focusing on relentless execution
and attention to detail.
And finally, and most importantly,
making the whole of my skills
greater than the sum of their parts
while connecting them to my purpose
and my vision of the future.
The outcome of this magic has been
the tremendous success of MSCI.
I recognize that everyone here
wants to be a unicorn.
Raise their hand, who doesn't?
But before I conclude,
[LAUGH] I guess a few hands there.
let me remind you that we all need
a higher mission in life.
There are 8 billion people on this
planet, and GSB graduates are among
the extremely privileged.
You have a responsibility to
the privilege bestowed upon you.
Use it to change the world and
live a purposes life.
And yes, I mean, everything else,
please remember to do the dishes.
>> [LAUGH] >> God speed, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE]
>> It is now my great honor and
pleasure to introduce the GSB PhD
class of 2023.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Our PHD program is small and
exclusive with an admission rate
under 6%.
These individuals came here as
students dedicating themselves to
two or three years of coursework,
followed by an intensive research
apprenticeship in their chosen
fields.
Having become true experts, they
leave us as colleagues setting out
on a path to create new knowledge,
which we know will help change
the world of business and
management for the better.
Today, we formally celebrate
the transition of these folks from
students to future intellectual
leaders who will play an important
role in shaping our understanding
of business in management.
After their advisors place the hood
of the Stanford Graduate School of
Business on them, they will join us
on the stage as we welcome them as
colleagues into our profession.
Diane Lee, Assistant Dean of
the PhD program, will now read
their names and their dissertation
advisor will hook them.
>> Wen Jia Ba.
Wen Jia's research explores how
online platforms including online
advertising and virtual assistants
like Alexa or Siri can adapt their
user behavior by using advanced
tools like machine learning,
optimization and game theory.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Martino Bunkyo,
Martino investigates the impact of
artificial intelligence on digital
markets and whether AI could
facilitate collusion.
He designs new AI-aware digital
markets.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Daniel Chen,
Daniel's research shows how
competing multi-sided platforms
such as Facebook and
Twitter can be embedded into
a general equilibrium framework.
He uses this model to analyze
the impact of these platforms on
the broader economy and
develops insights into how these
platforms should be regulated.
[APPLAUSE] >> George Jitta Guay.
George's research uses modern
causal inference methods to explore
behavioral economics in real world
settings.
His work informs our understanding
of how different policies and
information designs can affect
businesses and consumers.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Z Yang Kang.
Z Yang's research focuses on
market design, mechanism design and
industrial organization.
By applying a theoretical lens to
policy design and evaluation,
Z Yang's research helps to create
economic systems that are more
efficient and more equitable.
[APPLAUSE] >> Rupali Kahl.
Through a large-scale
study conducted in Rwanda, Rupali's
research focuses on developing
small and medium firms by making
them more customer-centric, and
by adopting marketing technologies.
Her research provides insights for
policy designed to alleviate
poverty and develop firms.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Douglas Laporte.
Douglas' research is about how
to improve machine learning
methods to predict stock returns.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sue Liu.
Sue's research explores stock
market reactions to monetary shocks
through a novel demand-based
mechanism.
Her work unveils the crucial
role of intermediaries' demand in
monetary transmission through her
preferences for target share
between equities and bonds.
[APPLAUSE] >> Lina Lukianseva.
Lina's dissertation investigates
the value of information and
learning in the context of
recommendation systems,
oligopolies, and markets for data.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Shweita Maria Fasu.
Shwita's research examines
the psychological and behavioral
consequences of technology mediated
recommendations including how
the personalization and modality
of delivery influence consumers.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Abraham Oshotsky.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Abraham's research
uses survey methods and
computational linguistics to
investigate the mechanisms and
consequences of
culturally determined behavior
in the context of markets,
organizations, and broader society.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Natasha Overmeyer.
Natasha's research examines how
entrepreneurs acquire funding
through their vision of the future
and how investors evaluate early
stage startups.
She studies how evaluative
practices may shape the startup
funding ecosystem with attention to
inequality and misconduct.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Edo Specter.
Edo studies the effect of CEOs
early life environments on their
propensity to commit financial
fraud and- [SOUND] >> Engage
in mergers and acquisitions.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ulises Velazquez.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ulises studies how
the supply of credit during
the times of crisis can greatly
depends on the type of
financial intermediary.
He also examines how monetary
policy affects the refinancing
decisions of landlords and
in turn how this affects the rental
prices that tenants pay.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Paul Ficinanza.
Paul's research develops tools from
natural language processing, and
deep learning to illuminate how
social structures mold knowledge
and culture.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Lulu Weng.
Stores pay high fees to accept
credit cards so
that consumers get rewards.
Lulu's research shows that this is
bad and- [SOUND] >> That new
payment apps like Affirm or
PayPal can make it worse.
[APPLAUSE] >> Jonathan Zeller.
Jon studies the trade offs that
govern how consumers make choices
in digital environments,
including subscription software and
TV streaming.
His work helps us understand
the implications of a firm's
decision such as when to release
episodes of streaming TV shows
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Charles Zhang.
Charles studies the value of
salespeople's efforts and
how information about consumer
behavior can be use to accurately
measure the value of these efforts.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Mingxi Zhu.
Mingxi's research focuses on
developing large-scale optimization
algorithms to facilitate managing
vast amounts of data,
making effective decisions,
and assessing business
strategies in a short time span.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE] >> Good afternoon,
it is my pleasure as Director of
the Stanford MSX program,
to present this year's graduates
who received the degree of Master
of Science in Management.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> The mission of the MSX program
is to provide experienced leaders,
people who have spent at least
eight years in professional and
management roles, the opportunity
to prepare themselves for
increasing senior positions in
organizations they will lead.
MSX students participate in a full
time year long course of academic
study, giving them an all too rare
chance for reflection and
growth in the midst of an already
promising career.
On behalf of the administration of
the program and
the faculty who have taught them,
join me in wishing each of them
great fulfillment and success
in the next phase of their career.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> In
honor of the service of former
GSB Dean Robert Joss, who was
himself a student in the program,
the top 10% of the MSX class,
ranked by academic performance, are
designated as Robert Joss Scholars.
As we read the names of the
graduates, we will also announce if
they have achieved the distinction
of Robert Joss Scholar.
Margaret Hayes, Associate Dean of
the MBA and MSX programs, will
now read our graduates' names while
Dean Levin presents the diplomas.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alaa Abdelrahim.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Olusola Adesanwo.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Javier Araya Kopaitic.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sebastian Balazs.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nare Bandaranayake.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Yulia Barinskaia.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Amit Bharti.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Carrie Bishop.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Atul Bist.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Mike Burnett,
Robert Joss Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ariel Cai.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Yun Hee Chang.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Alisha Chen Chen.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Peter Chiu.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hardik Umesh Choksi.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Brandon Chua,
Robert Joss Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Hillary Clevenger.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Margaret Coblentz.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Annamarie Dalka.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ksenia Delaittre,
Robert Joss Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Freddy Dominguez.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Cindy Dong.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Lacey Calac Dunne.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Yangpeng Devon Fu.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Felippe Galeb.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Vijay Garimella.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Pawan Gupta.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Bob Hoffman.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Piyal Hyder.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Shumpei Ishikawa.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ashtan Jordan.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Adam Kulick.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Priyanka Ladha.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ramanuj Lal.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Guillermo Lamsfus.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kim Latypov.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Bennett J Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> GW Gil Woo Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE] [APPLAUSE]
>> Matthew Lee, Robert Jha Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Peggy Jing Liao.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Cynthia Yutian La.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Allen Maddock,
Robert Joss Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Gaurav Manchanda.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Walter Kipkarir Mibay.
>> Shailesh Muralidara.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Wendy Lien Nguyen.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nour Ezzeldin Nour Hasnan,
Robert Jha Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Anant Padmanabhan.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Phoebe Park,
Robert Joss Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Tricia Patak.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Hector Perreira.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Federico Victor Potocnik.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Vladimir Potenko.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nicolas Restrepo Pelaez.
>> Emmy Sakurampochai.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Andres Salata.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ignacio Santillana Farrakos.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sifat Sarwar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sean Sasso.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Yuta Sato.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Arturo Sarakyan.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Omar Sheya.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Margot Zorowski-Stokem,
Robert Joss Scholar >> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nikitha Sushilkumar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Orshoya Sabo.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hideki Tamamaki.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Keisuke Tanigaki.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Hideki Tomita.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Alexiyei Utkin.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> David Vernal.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Reid Verucki.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Michael Ki Wong.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Vincent Wei Wong.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Fabiana Christina Yu.
>> Tatiana Zakarchenko.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Raiyut Zairi.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ore Zaitler.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Xanjian Chong.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Eric Dew.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Among the Robert L Joss
scholars, one student's academic
cchievement places them at the top
of the MSX class.
>> [LAUGH] >> This student is
awarded the George GC Parker Prize
named in honor of GSP faculty and
former program director,
Professor George Parker,
who is here with us today.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> The graduate
receives a certificate, a cash
award, and their name will be
on a plaque displayed at the GSB.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> The
recipient
of the
George
GC Parker
Prize is
Michael
Burnett.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Distinguished guests, faculty,
staff, families, and friends.
The MBA students gathered here
before us today have engaged in
a transformational experience.
They have acquired solid
foundations in general management
and have pursued deeper study in
their areas of interest.
They have engaged in perched
personal growth and
built relationships that will
last a lifetime.
They have helped the school and
community in many ways.
They are an impressive group and
are ready and worthy to join the
ranks of our illustrious alumni.
Therefore, it is my great honor and
privilege to present to you
the Stanford MBA Class of 2023.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE]
>> As you leave I hope your
memories of the GSB will remain
fresh, and that you will stay
involved with the school.
Our alumni played an important
role in your academic experience,
ranging from serving as judges in
the executive challenge to
acting as mentors in
entrepreneurial courses.
It is my wish that you too will
engage with GSB's academic mission
as alumni and give your time and
experience generously to future
classes.
You will leave your own legacy and
play a part in bringing the GSB
experience to future generations as
other alumni have done before you.
All of you have undoubtedly heard
of RJ Miller,
RJ served in the US Air Force
during the Second World War, and
was later one of the so-called whiz
kids who revolutionized
the Ford Motor Company.
Arjay became President of Ford, and
then later, the much admired fourth
Dean of the GSB from 1968 to 1978.
In honor of Dean Miller's service,
the top 10% of the class ranked by
academic performance are designated
as RJ Miller Scholars.
As we read the names of
the graduates we will also announce
if they have achieved the academic
distinction of RJ Miller Scholar.
In the case of joint degree
students who are walking today but
not graduating we will identify
those who are currently in the top
10% of the class.
The late Dean Miller has also
founded the Certificate in Public
Management and Social Innovation
program here at the GSB.
The certificate program educates
leaders who understand societal
issues, design for and
evaluate impact, and understand
the specificities of the management
of social organizations in both
the private and public sectors.
This year we have 136 recipients.
Their names are listed in
the commencement program.
>> [LAUGH] >> You
never know what's going to land.
>> [LAUGH] >> Graduates names will
now be ready by Jamie Shine,
Assistant Dean of MBA Admissions
and Financial Aid and
by Margaret Hayes, Associate Dean
of the MBA and MSX programs.
Graduates will receive their
diplomas from Dean Lemon
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Giorgi Abayadze.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Mansoor Abbas.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Julia Abalski.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sarah Abushar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Adwan Adams.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Rahul Adhikari
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Taleha Aftab.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ipshita Agarwal.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ish Agarwal.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Oyendamola Adyayi.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Hannah Ashmani.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Aslam Akhort.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Tamar Al-Ghussain.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Enrique
Rocha Mankimbera Albuquerque.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dominique Anne Alpucci.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Anis Ann.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sarah Suwon Anderson.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sue Andrean.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Abby Arora.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Olivier Babin,
R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jordan
Jose George Badia-Bellinger.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jonathan Baer.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Arthur Bagramian.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Amanda Bakerly.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Marco Balog.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sancult Banerjee.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Rodolfo Bacarizo.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Julian Barber.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Gregory Douglas Barrow.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Drew Barvere.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Joel Bateman.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Aurora Beauclair.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Lu Bolu Larosh.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Edgar Alonso Bendazu Medina.
>> Jacob Jablon Bernstein.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andrew Marriott Bertha.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nanit Bala.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Krishna Bharathala.
>> Sher Singh Bhullar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jameson Charles Billings.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Mahul Brower.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE] >> James Brown.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Zack Button.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jeff Butler.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jordan Byers.
>> Jonah Gordon- Cater, R.J.
Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Laura Calderon-Arango.
>> Charlotte Eloise Camacho.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Lauren Canter.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alejandro Casa Diego.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Chingas Yimalolo.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Gabe Haralambidee.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Aman Chaudhry.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Claire Chen.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Emily Chen, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nina Chen.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Rohan Chen.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Teresa Chen.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Benjamin Shidaco.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Cameron Joseph Chism.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Hamsa Chathuri.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nicholas Chow.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Olga Patarina-Chomanskaya
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Alex Clark.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Chloe Ann Colberg.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nyamiche Ella Coleman.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Benjamin Collins.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Manuel Coquette.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Panagiotis Koutelas.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Claire Crozel.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Caleb Colt Cunningham.
>> Guilherme Cibes-Pereira.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Florian Dalhousen,
R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Audrey Elizabeth Dalton.
>> Dylan Davis-Daniels.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Alexa Davis.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Carolyn Marie Davis.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> George Davis.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Anibal DeFrankenberg.
>> Robert Allen DeWitt Jr.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Carlo Delano.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Matt Deco.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Rachel Ann Debner.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Audrey Elody Zemi-Gia.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Cathy Dong.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Wenqi Duan.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jennifer Nicole Dumiak.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Saeon Eddy.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andrew Christopher Edwards.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Leah Edwards.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Aaronstrom Shaw Elder, R.J.
Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sebastian Espinoza.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Eric Esposito.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Yekaterina Yevchenko.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Faraz Fadavi.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Daniel Fairman.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Syed Edmud Faraz.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Eric Daniel Pfeiffer.
>> Rose Antoinette Pana-Fisher.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Oren Flegelman.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Luis Flores.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sarah Seaborn Freeman.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nia Rose Froome.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jacob Gaba.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ryan Gairdner.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Catherine Crawford-Gamble, R.J.
Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jose Ignacio Garcia-Suarez.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kate Gautier, R.J.
Miller Scholar >> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nicholas Michael Gavin.
[APPLAUSE] >> Katherine Gea,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Divya Giyanani.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jamie Glavin.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ria Goel.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jason Gomez.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Camila Gonzalez Jaque.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Pedro
Alexander Gongzalez Hernandez.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andrew Thomas Greico.
>> Philippe Griffiths.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Erik Grossman.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Shalina Grover.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> John Guerci.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Pedro Guerrero.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Daphne Guillet de Chatellus.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ashirwad Gupta.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Saloni Gupta.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Yash Gupta.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Alex Gureev.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Anna Gurevich,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Inigo Gutierrez Fernandez.
>> Maria Gutierrez Penaloza.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Fransiska Hadiwidjana.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Lukas Haffer,
Arfay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Roy Hage.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kristin Cory Halvorsen.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Julien Ham-Ying,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Radwa Hamed.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Louise Hannecart.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> David Harrison.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Casey Hartless.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sophie Hasson.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Isabel Suzanne Hebert.
>> Preston Charles Hedrick.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alexis Sophia Henkel.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Adriana Holcek.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Cyerra Holmes.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Lilian Hommes.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Eliot Horen.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Alice Huang,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kevin Liu Huang.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Richard Huang.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Daniel Huf.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Daniel Thomas Huntley
>> Elspeth Viator Huscher.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Samina Hydery Burke.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sowa Imoisili.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Amanda Jayla Irizarry.
>> Medina Bakyt Isak-Orduna.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Madeline Jacks.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Yashvardhan Jain.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mohammad Abdi Jama.
>> Jamille Nicole Jamison.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Mollie Javerbaum.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Eshan Jayamanne.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alexandra Jenkins Chocano.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kelly Jiang,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Siran Jiang.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Avril Yue Jiao.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jenny Johnston.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hayley Briana Jones.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Dr.
Gabriel Preston Joseph.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kyo Kaku.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ellie Kang.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jonathan Karp,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE] >> Nolan Casper.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Muhammad Izzedine Kakuda.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Unkit Kawatra.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Anthony Najee Karoos.
>> Isabelle Frances Kerr,
top 10% of the current class.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ralph Khan.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Angela Hege.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jason Coo.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Albert Kim.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jason Kim.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Mingyu Kim.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jessica King Fridell.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Fernandina Ko.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Harshit Kohli.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Joseph Coleman.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Georgia Jean Kossoff.
>> Sarah Marie Kulajorge.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sammie Labose.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Matan Lambdan.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jessica Landsberg.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> John Cedric Lauhu.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Elizabeth Larson,
R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Cola Lawal.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Albert P Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Diane Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jay Joe Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Katie Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> McKenzie Elizabeth Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kevin Lang,
R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ivo Paolo Santos Lima Jr.
>> Karli Danielle Linsenberg.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> David Mason Leo,
R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Zachary Lintner.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Matthew Lidovitz.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Laura Liu.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Stella Liu.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Shwan Liu.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Gerald Adam Long,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ryan Lopez.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jonathan Vanderplat Lorenz.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sophia Lugo.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kanyan Ma.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Eric Michael McBlain.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Rosie McLennan.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Michael Madding.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andrea Madero Franco.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Matthew Madsen,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Irfan Mahmood.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Tamir Meixner.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Monique Malcolm Hay.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Dorsa Malik.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Mariama Mala.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Mohawk Mungal.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Raghav Manimaran.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Miles Hamilton Mann.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Rocio Marazuela.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Anne Sophie Martin.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Marcus Martinelli.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Christobal Maturana.
>> Elizabeth Bailey McGee.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Amanda McClain.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Flavia Medina De Cunha.
>> Charlotte Julie Myrstad.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Yoslin Melgar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Veronica Mercado.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Marissa Gram Messina.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Laura Mechulex
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Natalie Ann Muir.
[APPLAUSE] >> Ana Carolina Mejia.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alexander Spiridon Mihalichos.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Yuta Miki.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Diletta Didi Milana.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nicole Miles.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Catherine Miller.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Andrew Minarik
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Elise Menken.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Shanice Mohinani.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Zachary Mooring.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Andrei Molchenski.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Joe Molina.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Matthew Molloy.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nabil Momin.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Georgia Moody,
R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Bruno Morato Fadia.
>> Jackson Bruce Morton II.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Gabriel Moynihan.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Anisha Mudaliar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Masahiro Nakanishi.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nikhil Raj Nair.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Paul Alexander Nelson.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Akiva Nemetsky,
R.J. Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Tuy Anh Nguyen.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Paola Nisioli.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Genevieve De La Balm-Nielsen.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Lasse Nieberg.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Neil Charles O'Hara.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Thomas O'Neill
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ray Oakley.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sanver Overroy.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Tara Olivera.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Deanna Orlandi.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Carly Osborne.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Tere Kwame Renee Owen.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Connor Owens.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andrea Fagola DuChateau.
>> Antonia Pallades Gonzalez.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Imani Lynn Parker-Fong.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Santiago Patarka.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kaya Patel.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jeremy Pathmanaban.
>> Roberto Pasmino-Arguello.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Brian Pegno,
R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Bruno Pereira-Fajaguch.
>> Mook Pantela Sangthong.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Zika Frances Elbert-Philip.
>> Katherine Rene Playfair.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Matthew Podlasak.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Karen M Poley.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jeff Canto.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ariane Portores.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nell Candler Potter.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jolly Chion.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Maximilian Krishermas.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Steven Racheski.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Clay Rafe.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Shaibea Rajbhandari.
>> Tanvi Nikita Vikasraji.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Varun Ram.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Suleka Ramaya,
R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Diego Ramirez-Aguilar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Logan B Randall.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Luke Ren.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jeffrey Ripucci,
top 10% of the current class.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Camilla Ray,
R.J. Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Daniel Reyes Elizondo.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Hannah Richards,
R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] [APPLAUSE]
>> India Richter.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Matthew O'Neill Ricotta.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Michael Roberts.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Wesley Rodriguez.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Julieta Romero.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Timothy J Rosenberger, Jr.
>> Elizabeth Rosenblatt,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Joshua Russell
Rowley, RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jonathan Rosenberg.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Becca Ruin.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Megan Ruin.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sergio Rujeda-Linares.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nishad Ruparel.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Alex Ruvalcaba.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Luke Ryan Schreiber.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nina Sabarwal.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Juan Pablo Saez-Vera.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Scott Sage.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Khande Sala.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Richard Saliba,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Julia Salas.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Carl Sandberg.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Daniel Sandoval-Quintero.
>> Jonathan Andrew Sands,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Rafael Sands.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Tal Sarig.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Abhinav Sachivarapu.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nate Schlein.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Zach Schloss, RJ Miller Scholar.
>> Jacqueline Schuller.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Samantha Virginia Schwab.
>> Kathleen Kimya Schwend.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Hannah Sears.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Julia Marisa Sekula.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Michael Shaw.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kevin Shaw,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Madeline Shannon.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Max Shen,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jay Shum.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Maria de Lourdes Silva Wilson.
>> Laura Catherine Simcoe.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Ikshida Singh.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Elizabeth Sterling-Sipp,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Amy Slaughter.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jarrett Smith.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kyle Stanford-Smith.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Joseph Lee-Song,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Renny Song.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> David Steiner.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kate Eater Steinman.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sonny Stevens.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jackson Stone.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thomas James Stone.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Hugh Sullivan,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sarah Lorraine Sullivan.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Tejas Sundaresan.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kareem Tabaja.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Yasu Tejada.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Midori Takasaki.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alexandra Emiko Takei.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Felicity Tang,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Xiaowen Tang.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kathryn Charleson.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Drew Tapam.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sydney Topper.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Juan Pablo Trevino.
>> [APPLAUSE] [APPLAUSE]
>> David Troner.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Robyn Tse.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Darwin Valentine.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> James Van Kirk.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Samuel Veloso.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Antonio Vera.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Maria Victoria Verbaite.
>> Brandon Eric Vincent-Comolli.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> David Wagura.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Grant Wallace,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Cory Truman Waltrip.
>> Christina Ningyue Wang.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nancy Wang.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Marshal Thomas Watkins.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Lia Weiner Soar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Elizabeth Dowling Weiss.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Yoni Weiss.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Andrea Wenrich.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> C William Wester Jr.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Kayla Ann Wester.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Cooper Wetherbee,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sean Wheelock.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Louise Giesey White.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Bryce Wilberding.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jonathan Wilkins,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Megan Wood.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Antonia Elizabeth Woodford,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Evangeline Woodforde.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Colin Woolway.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Davis Wu.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Oceane Wu.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nancy Xu.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> James Yan.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Sam Yarosh.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Chuo Rong Yeo.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Christopher Yuan.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Karine Yuki.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Claire Yun.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Nina Yun.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Eduardo Zaldivar.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jiayi Daqi Zhai.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Amy Guohua Zhao.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Jess Zhu.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Yutong Zhu.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Justin Ziegler.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Michael Thomas Zincone.
>> Nominated and chosen by their
peers, the recipient of the Ernest
C Arbuckle Award is the second year
MBA student who by their active
participation, initiative,
leadership, and personal integrity.
Is judged as having contributed
most to the fulfillment of
the goals of the Graduate School of
Business in their actions both
within school and society.
We are delighted to
have Susan Arbuckle, the daughter
of Ernie Arbuckle, with us today.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> The recipient
receives a cash prize and
also has their name on a plaque on
display at the GSB.
This year's recipient of the award
is Keya Patel.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE] >> The Alexander
Robichek Student Achievement Award
in Finance was established to honor
Professor Robichek's outstanding
contribution to the teaching
of finance at the GSB
from 1960 until his death in 1978.
The award is given to an MBA
student selected by the finance
faculty for outstanding achievement
in their finance courses.
The recipient receives the award
and has their name on display at
the GSB.
This year's recipient of the
Robichek Award is Joshua Rowley.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And finally, among the RJ Miller
scholars, one student's
academic achievement places
them at the top of the class.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> This student is
designated as the Henry Ford,
the II Scholar and
receives a significant cash reward
and- >> [APPLAUSE] >> And
their name displayed at the GSB.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> I am very proud to
announce that this year's recipient
of the Henry Ford II Scholar Award
is Elizabeth Rosenberg.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Honored guests, faculty staff,
families, and friends,
we have reached the conclusion of
our ceremony.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Guests,
I ask you to please remain seated
until the graduates recess.
And I invite you all to join us at
the Nape Management Center for
reception.
Graduates, please stand.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> What a journey it has been.
Let's have one final
round of applause for
the GSB class of 2023.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Graduates, you may recess.
[MUSIC]